Sur l’île de la Réunion, dans l’océan Indien,
le piton de la Fournaise est entré en éruption.
Contrairement aux volcans de l’arc antillais par exemple,
dont l’activité est liée
aux mouvements des plaques tectoniques,
le piton de la Fournaise est un volcan
dit de point chaud.
A 2900 km sous nos pieds, à l’aplomb de la Réunion
le noyau terrestre libère une partie de son énergie.
Sous l’effet de la chaleur, un énorme panache
de matière chaude remonte à la verticale.
Parvenu en surface, le magma s’accumule
dans une chambre magmatique
et sous l’effet de la pression, il finit par jaillir à l’extérieur.
On ne parle plus de magma mais de lave.
C’est ce qui s’est passé, il y a quelques jours,
sur le piton de la Fournaise
et depuis, la lave s’écoule sur le flanc Est du volcan.
Allez, promis, à la prochaine éruption,
je vous y emmène avec « le Monde de Jamy »,
une « méga capsule de déconfiné.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...